I'll do the same oh you can bring it up
if you want okay you're listening to the
dollop on the all things comedy Network
this is an American history podcast each
week I Dave Anthony read story from
American history to a guy I know named
Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is going to be about oh you don't
know
sounds like you hate me really does it's
coming across in the intro yeah I don't
know if you've read the read it buddy
but I did read that read it comment
let's go that's fine I do but not on air
we're in character now once we're on
this end it can be the Alphaville
awkward people don't know that when
we're not when we're not on recording
when we're not recording we usually
punch each other in the face about seven
times a minute yeah yep yep so it's just
over one every ten seconds yeah yeah
yeah no I mean it's weird who knows Dave
who knows that guy also sent me a
private message saying how mean I was to
you okay this guy I like I like this guy
I don't know who he is
what he's doing but he's on top of
things yeah he gets it no we clearly
hate each other I mean people one of the
two guys is a k-rock or there's no
there's two morning guys in LA and they
hate each other so much Kevin a beam
that one moved to Seattle and had a t1
installed in his house and so they
haven't been in the same room in like
eight years and they do morning radio
every morning and they're people think
they're in the same room and they hate
each other's guts it's great I can't let
that squad goals I can't wait to get
there
[Music]
well know what just based on the what
you're just doing what anything
sexualizing your phone people know that
if they want to see the podcast this
episode you can go to the all things
comedy YouTube page where we have a
bunch of dynamic performances by us um I
wasn't sexualizing I was being an idiot
you were sexualizing your phone no I was
I was thinking about hang out like a
[ __ ] no you were licking like he were
it was pretty body but here at it was
hot pretty rad and hot dates coming up
yes dates so I will be a lot of places
this summer I will be June 6th through
the 8th that'll be at good night's
comedy club in Raleigh North Carolina
I'll be in Burlington Vermont at the
Vermont comedy club June 13th through
the 15th the comedy attic in Bloomington
Indiana the 20th through the 22nd June
27th through the 29th I'll be at comedy
off Broadway Lexington said Kentucky not
to be confused with on on Broadway in
July 19th and 20th
I'll be at laughs Boston in July then
August 9th through the 11th the improv
in Denver Seattle of July 17th I'll be
at the Fremont Abbey and then it will
all culminate at comedy on state and
Madison Wisconsin
August 22nd through the 24th it will
culminate and yeah oh and I'll be
recording an album at the Saturday show
August 20 that's what you say yeah I'll
be recording
not all culminate I'm recording an album
yeah but you know I mean it's alright
we'll get there I'm record no you give
people incited now you get him buying
tickets
the reddit like people come on this is
an act yes
tada yeah so that weekend and I guess
one of those nights I'll tell I'll say
which one I'll be recording an album
soon yeah yeah it'll be great
it'll be great it's on your niece's
birthday that was a mistake last night
we went to the LAF see less do you ever
go to those games la FC I haven't been
yet dude they are so great it's so great
that's might be the best part to see in
Los Angeles hockey when we went I mean
how sad was that but that's they were
terrible like they can't play hockey
right now but previously it's the best
night we hung all the Tom Hanks on Mike
Royce we did hang on Tom Hanks I'm
locking my curse hey we might have some
exciting news coming up about England we
are brought to you by zip recruiter ah
Gare Cory that's right hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
can go where hiring is simple fast and
smart a place where growing businesses
connect to qualified candidates the
place is zip or cooter dot-com slash
dollop now you hire what do you hire you
have people that need to lift a cat
correct I've people there's cat lifters
there's a lot of stuff maintenance a
bunch of stuff keep the food away from
the cat the cat
we have fluffers we have a whole bunch
of gear core we are a versatile business
is there anybody that milks the milks
the cat I don't think that zip recruiter
sends you jobs over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
resumes to find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job so if you're a cat milker this
is it applications come in and zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the first day and right now our
listeners Frank and sandy mm-hmm
can try zip recruiter for free what get
out I said it
what yes at this web address zip
recruiter dot-com slash dollop that's
zip recruiter com slash dollop do ll o P
you guys know how to spell it zip
recruiter calm a slash dollop yep and
you've hired how many people 30,000
30,000 people doing I'm doing it
Undercover Boss sure I'm Garrick or I
love it I just to see what things I can
change in the versatile that's all did a
zipper career oh yeah yeah
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
Gareth yes David
you sleep right once I did once yeah
when you sleep do you sleep on a
mattress with no sheets I sleep on a
mattress with terrific she you do yeah
so does Jose well I bet you're talking
about Brooklyn and calm yeah you spend a
third of your life in sheets hopefully
I'm aiming for a half I know right
yeah just that's that's right right at
the level where you're not getting bed
sores that's where I want to be right
yeah right below bed sores where I want
to be well it's about time for a betting
upgrade talk about oops
Brooklyn sheets were named winner of the
best online betting category by Good
Housekeeping hmm a bad housekeeping did
I mention them yeah but they're the
worst yes those people are you
nightmares yeah yeah rave reviews from
Business Insider Apartment Therapy and
men's health 35,000 plus five-star
reviews more than any other online
betting company they were founded in
early 2014 by husband and wife Vicky and
rich Fulop sure the flops yeah
isn't that a dollar spin off their
mission was to make five-star quality
hotel sheets more affordable and easy to
order luxury sheets without the luxury
markup most bedding is marked up 300%
what yeah most remarkable areas [ __ ]
furniture nonsense is right it is okay
these guys weren't taking it okay so the
sheets don't
just feel great they look great to you
of course have a dark-brown correct a
chocolate-brown
I'm not gonna take the bait but I have
no I don't actually
you have a gray gray and when you sleep
and you drool is there a big stains
what's happening right now well what
sort of does does does Jose leave like a
stain of any sort when he when he what
no the milk comes out of him
well I've milked him before bed dummy
what do you think I'm drinking in the
night that's fine yeah cat milk attd
milk
Brooklyn and has a Brooklyn has over 25
plus colors and patterns to make your
bedroom just right are Brooklyn cheats
of the best most comfortable sheets
we've ever slept on now it's time for
your upgrade Brooklyn and calm is giving
an exclusive offer just for our
listeners get 10% off your first order
and free shipping when you use a promo
code that dollop at Brooklyn and calm
Brooklyn is so confident in their
product that all the sheets comforters
and towels come with a lifetime warranty
the only way to get 10% off your first
order and for shipping is to promo code
if you don't like if you [ __ ] your
sheets you're like we're no condom you
go hey you did that if it just like
wears through or like a hole pops up or
whatever okay it's like not like a game
this is the item so the only way to get
10% off your first order and free
shipping is to use promo code the dollop
at Brooklyn and calm that's BR oh okay
line1 code the dollop Brooklyn and these
really are the best sheets average
sheets we are also brought to you by
third love now you enjoy bras
I love bra yeah well third lady is my
mother my mother used to find bras in my
basement we're drinking down here now to
see you know look third linen is a
brassiere that's about what's coming
towards me thank you saving third linen
is a broad company perfect fit you know
that yes they use data points generated
by millions of women who've taken their
fit finder quiz to design bras with the
breast size and shape in mind for a
perfect fit and premium
feel sure more sizes than other brands
70 sizes more than 70 sizes including
half cup sizes interesting yeah so it's
like a breakthrough situation right
right they're a convenience obviously
you can go on third loves online fit
finder order trout at home no more
awkward fitting room experiences
well awkward for not for you okay I was
gonna say I'm finally yeah you're good
yeah 100% guarantee every customer has
60 days to wear it wash it and put it to
the test and if you don't love it return
it and third level wash it and donate to
a woman in need why why would you not
just for shits and giggles just if you
have like 60 days to wear and tear a bra
just order one and go have a little fun
wear it around town just really see what
you can do play some volleyball you know
what I mean
the look you're giving me is weird it's
okay but I'm just saying that you could
really you know it's you have two
options get a great bra or just have a
fun time if it's sort of like a little
bucket list with a bra just go bananas
third loves team of expert to fit
stylists are dedicated to helping you
find your perfect fit fit stylists are
available every day to help be a text
chat or phone
I might text someone text about that bra
third love knows there's a perfect bra
for everyone so right now they're
offering our listeners 15% off your
first order go to third love comm slash
dollop now to find your perfect fitting
bra and get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love comm / dollop for 15%
off today boom
we gotta get a jockstrap yeah sponsor
yeah I agree
let's end the show what do you mean
uh-huh I'm sorry I sound out I thought
we were about to fight what do we fight
we hate each other in more fights on no
offer often time gotcha yeah so hey
friend
hi I really like you
1875 okay low year by Lord Jesus Christ
this this episode is brought to you by
Jesus therefore you owe to save you
you know after hearing the other ads and
his he just doesn't seem to offer super
he's just super into basic simple stuff
he's like keep it super real and keep it
really quick yeah it's not really the
market for that yeah all right Edward
Eastman was born in coley-cole ears hook
section of lower Manhattan I never heard
of that
really choral ears coral ears hoax
section okay what's his name have you
heard of that no Edward Eastman okay his
mom was Mary his father was Samuel he
was a veteran of the Civil War okay
Samuel was now working as a wallpaper
hanger a great industry at the time
killing it yeah killing it he so they
lived on the Lower East Side for at
least five years before that we know
they had been in California they had one
son Willie who was three in 1870 but
then he didn't show up anymore censuses
so we're going to make the assumption he
died or you know ran all at three one
off his own career yeah yeah
by the time Edward reached five his dad
left so Samuels out okay good stuff
leaving Mary to raise the kids on her
own the family event had to move in with
Mary's father George he was living on
the Upper East Side okay his grandfather
was 69 and worked in a dry goods store
sure for dry stuff yeah for he was not
into wet peppers and Jerky's and yeah
yep yep Edward had three sisters Lizzie
Ida and Francine the family had clearly
spent some my other side California
Samuel died when Edward was 14 okay he
he his dad had remained in the Lower
East Side all that time and he died of
consumption in the house of rest for
consumptives
so he was in the right place to die with
right yeah yeah what should we name it
well let's really let's call it on the
nose hospital mary had already been
saying she was a widow for years so she
was already like yeah he's dead okay
so he's just holding up his end of the
bargain yeah edward was super inanimate
and really he was into pigeons you
really liked pigeons okay he's on the
right city yeah yeah it was very common
for kids to catch pigeons or steal them
and then sell them back then sell a
pigeon yeah who are you selling a pigeon
to the pigeon guy who is buying a pigeon
in the land where you can just go pick
up a pigeon bankers it's just a deposit
well you couldn't just pick up a pigeon
you had to catch it and I don't think
it's easy to catch a pigeon you ever
tried to catch a pigeon when you're a
kid no not easy but I seen rocky do it
okay so that's a chicken okay well I
don't know people want them I think
people do and what are people doing with
the pigeon well you know we have you
ever seen uh like one of those movies
where there's a guy on a roof and then a
guy goes up to talk to him and there's a
bunch of pigeons in a cage what yeah
that that's what's going on I don't
think that's accurate but you're just
people are just domesticating the
pigeons yeah I think you keep I think
you keep pigeons and and it's a pigeon
collection you don't know you have no
roof you've got no idea sometimes John
wick comes up and like hey I need I need
some help
yeah or it's John Woo yeah he's either
like hey so the kids who caught pigeons
were called pigeon chasers sure so
Edwards a patient chaser great I'm not a
good crew no then he started keeping
some pigeons for himself in a crudely
constructed cage on the roof of his
building
okay so but don't act like you have been
validated by something you knew was
coming where else are you gonna keep
pigeons in New York in the [ __ ]
basement or in your bedroom that's right
everybody puts them on the roof
everybody have you seen you are talking
like Trump
have you seen movies yes oh you mean
these documentaries called fictional
movies yeah don't adjust yourself for
anything
totally you are out of your mind and out
of line
so he he used to ler of them with other
pigeons
hey so he'd have pigeons and then other
pages would come and then he'd catch him
okay he could track he could trap up to
40 pigeons a week doing this and make
money he could sell them for ten to
twenty-five cents each and a factory
worker made a buck fifty a day so he
could actually make a decent living as a
pigeon chase you have to be eating the
pigeons yeah I mean maybe if you're
selling a pigeon yeah these people are
not taking pigeons like I've just been
looking for a pet maybe they're shooting
them or they're eating them in some
capacity they might be yeah they might
be eating I think they're eating yeah
Edward was also do stealing and fighting
a lot okay table hobbies sure the worst
depression the country had seen hit in
1893 thousands out of work - well those
show the term bread line was created ah
that's nice yeah six thousand beggars in
ten times as many homeless were in New
York City along with the street kids
which we've obviously discussed gangs of
course preyed on the street kids then
they controlled lower Manhattan okay
Edwards grandfather tried to keep him on
the straight and narrow and at one point
set him up with his own pet store in
Brooklyn okay because he loves animals
pigeon excuse pigeon well he likes cats
also likes all animals I like this guy
I'm just a little worried but then then
Gramps died and things went in another
direction
being a small pet store owner did not
suit Edward okay he wanted more and he
was soon hanging out with a gang of
pimps and thieves who are known as the
Allen Street Cadets okay
Edward used Irish names like William
Delaney he that's what he was going as
yeah okay because it's better to be
Irish down there he's still a teenager
okay so late teens late teens so William
Delaney because there's so many Irish
gangs down there that it helps to be
Irish also there's some
their authentication tests were pretty
weak obviously yeah you just say your
name oh alright well that's an Irish
name alright as you were mate sorry
about that
my name is Tom Peters [ __ ] there some
people think he was Jewish but Delaney
is not Jewish no no I mean I've said
he's fake characters not Jewish sorry ok
fair but a lot of people said he wasn't
and like he was he's probably Protestant
so whatever I didn't go into the whole
religious stuff which a lot of people go
into ok so also another reason to be
Irish Tammany Hall right you're
connected with the politicians if you're
in a gang sure Irish yeah you can get
that pigeon pill that's right yeah yeah
he also went by William Murray and
sometimes monk Eastman and other names
but monk is what he's known as today I
said people will refer to a minister
okay even though you rarely use that
name sure yeah it all makes sense of
course there's nothing weird
he was now known to police but because
he used different names they always they
they thought he was William Delaney or
somebody else like they catch him he's a
different name there was like no way to
you didn't have ID back time he just go
like what's your name kid Frank Frank
O'Neill that was the best I remember in
high school a couple times I was at
places where like parties would get
busted in the cot before I had ID and
the cops would be like what's your name
and it was just like the best yes and
that's what all life was yeah it sounds
great once when he was arrested he
actually said his name was Edward
Eastman but a cop in the station jumped
up and yelled quote I know him his
name's William Delaney
that's monk that's who that is so he was
arrested for many minor offenses like
stealing pigeons so you weren't allowed
to steal pigeons no if it's someone
else's pigeon you can't steal it's not
anyone else's pigeon no that's catching
opinion but we're talking money well
steal I can't just go up on the roof
they're all at every building has roof
you talking about
pigeon roofs
mock up married in 1896 or not March to
a monks yeah he's not a real monk oh
right
he was 22 monks first serious arrests
came in 1898 he was caught with burglary
tools he told the cops his name is
William Murray and that's the name he
went to jail under for three months okay
so so Edward doesn't know where you're
just hanging out in jail so monk is
small he's 5 feet 5 inches tall and 150
pounds okay but that's normal for them
right according to police records the
average gang member was 5 foot 3 inches
tall and weighed a hundred and twenty to
135 pounds so what's happened to us
since then have we just like well they
weren't eating good back then nicely and
then and then in times of like of
economic you know recession stuff they
would eat even less so right there was a
malnutrition now grown we eat so much of
there's so many antibiotics yeah we're
probably just like yeah we're all much
bigger than they were actually took a
pic cuz characters get off super and a
peaky blinders and I was when I was
doing this research I came across a
picture and I took a picture and I sent
it to her and she's like look at how
tall they are and they and then it cuz
it had it was the police snip and
they're all five three and five four
it's [ __ ] crazy you need scale so
some look small he had messy hair he he
wore a he wore a derby okay that was two
sizes too small so so he looked like
some sort of like yes it was just like
perched on the top of his head carnival
monkey like a carnival monkey right like
a carnival monkey he's just got a little
baby hat on got a baby hat on he had
gold capped teeth and he liked to hang
out in the gangs
club without his shirt on or in torn up
clothes
so this guy is okay it's quite a look
okay there he is oh jeez he's got a real
mush face
yeah I mean he that's I probably not yet
but he got into a lot of fights so
that's what happened to his face well
his tie looks tiny from a description of
Monk quote he began life with a bullet
shaped head who's describing this I
think I think that means that you know
sometimes when you come out of the old
whoo hole when you're a baby
oh yeah that's a that's a legal term
legal term yeah it's these in court he
came out of the old whoo hole and
sometimes you get a little-a little
pointing action and if you laid the kid
down and don't turn them over it stays
pointy so that's why you see little kids
and helmets I just thought there are
dirt bikers there trying to reshape that
head so yeah I know that but well it's
also that you know you can get that uh
that's sort of you know back of the head
like a coffee table if you're not
careful you got to rotate them
who's watching these children where
they're just like oh we forgot about it
for four days now he's a plank of wood I
don't know if they knew to rotate him
back man I mean who knows hmm or or his
parents didn't care you know yeah it
feels more like that um so begin life
with a bullet shaped head and during his
turbulent career acquired easier to get
a bullet shaped kid out of the hole true
just fires out he acquired it the
catcher's mitt
here we go choices no catchers man no he
acquired a broken nose and a pair of
cauliflower ears that's what I'm saying
he had heavily veined sagging jowls a
short bull neck plentiful planet
plentifully scarred with battle marks as
where his cheeks okay so you can see
he's got a lot of yeah he's looks like a
fighter yeah and he was he was a badass
fighter amongst fighting reputation
landed him a job working as a sheriff in
the Silver Dollar saloon okay so in
saloon instead of a bouncer you would
have a sheriff of your bar well we've
got a whole police force sheriffs in the
1890s were not the same thing as a
sheriff now it is more of a bouncer okay
but with totally ready to do whatever
they wanted so so I guess exactly
sheriff
a sheriff a bar share like our sheriffs
in LA have actually gang tattoos right
there in sheriff gangs
let's see here yeah cool yeah it's
really good good so this is where he
became super well-known monk would walk
around with a four-foot locust which is
a police stick made out of a kind of
wood the locust woods I called it so
which is harder than any other kind of
wood right and it's almost his size yeah
it's almost as big as him he had a black
jack in his pocket and brass knuckles on
each hand what is a black jack
that's the like LED I think I'm pretty
sure it's the leather thing that's like
full of like LED or whatever so now I
can just crack someone I might be wrong
but I'm pretty sure that so this if it
came to it he also was very good using a
beer bottle so if he had to improvise
beer bottle for each guy kicking the
crab who's bad with using a beer bottle
in a fight oh it's not that easy I feel
like I could pick it up really literally
for each guy he kicked the crap out of
he would carbon notch in his police
stick he would also beat up anyone who
he heard have been cruel to animals this
guy this is another one of these guys
where I'm like doing the hokey-pokey I'm
in on them out I don't know what's going
on in life like I do like that yeah for
sure especially in this era this is when
people are like cats are here for kickin
what yeah in oh in this air I thought
how about today no good Lord not in this
era no monk moved up in the sheriff
world and landed a job at new irving
hall which is a much bigger they're much
more popular place dances held there
with a lot of like lower belly criminal
types hmm hey quick has got a reputation
as the most brutal sheriff around
he was even worse than eat him up Jack
McManus who worked at suicide Hall what
just happened what did you just say to
me sir bite your tongue what is his name
eat him up Jack meat lamb chops Jack
McManus yeah he would eat him up sounds
like a jack-in-the-box bird he's beat
the [ __ ] out of him okay he worked it
suicide halt sure known that way cuz so
many women jumped off the building to
kill themselves what yeah
okay why bad parties how did they get up
there with all the pigeons on the roof
yeah dummy after about six months on the
job Monken hurt so many people who
needed to go to surgeons ambulance
drivers started referring to the
accident ward at Bellevue Hospital as
the Eastman Pavillion wait because he
sent so many people there yeah Wow okay
on the night he hit 49 victims notched
in his nightstick he just went up and
cracked an innocent guy standing at the
bar to make it an even 50 you know how
it is you're so eager to get over the
hump number you don't - wait that's
annoying late it might be late at night
you're like this place is gonna close
every day since he'd gotten someone in
that house gotta go to 50 yeah I mean he
even wanted 54 so long sir bathroom here
ah deserved it monk became someone young
man growing up in lower Manhattan looked
up to sure the first who became part of
his crew were the assistants at the hall
and then others came they imitated his
speech and his mannerisms organically a
school of east monk of monk Eastman
criminals and brawlers was born a school
so they just all wanted to be like him
so he was shown on the ropes he's like
their God they would fight anyone
anywhere for anything
monk resigned from his job and became a
gang leader so he went full time he went
full time I get benefits all right okay
right so he's like well I got a bunch of
kids who can do his job as a sheriff was
not in his mind close enough to being
sort of like a gang person well now he
can now but now he can make money like
real money cuz they'll be head of the
gang and he can send them out to do
crime okay so he'd send them out to
pickpocket and send the kids out yeah so
this is a real Oliver situation we've
got going yeah yeah he's [ __ ] he's
building a business I love it do like
Oliver he sent them out to pickpocket
and steal all the city they also worked
as lookouts runners and bodyguards soon
he is asking for tributes from criminals
operating on what became his turf
tributes being money yeah okay his
territory now stretched from the Bowery
to the East River okay at this time the
older gang some people may have heard of
were gone the dead rabbits the pug
uglies the why who's on the wires I have
a picture that we've heard of the pug
uglies before right yeah the pedigrees
have been in a lot of stuff that's the
why use BIOS in every badasses they
don't look very good no they look scary
anybody I mean a lot of these people
just look scary in general so these
three gangs had merged and turned into
the five points gang
yeah guys we came to an agreement we've
read it so they're also around 50
smaller gangs in the area who owed
allegiance to larger gangs
okay so the big gangs were the gophers
the gas houses the Hudson dusters and
now the Eastman's sure if a gang war
broke out the smaller gangs would fight
under the banner of a larger gang okay
so you have just kind of like auxilary
gangs like you have a smaller gang that
works under you sure and if you need
reinforcements you call in the smaller
gang right other than that they're
independent right but they will there's
sort of independent contractors yeah
will join your gang during times of need
yes okay sure makes total sense yeah in
the 1900 census monks job was listed as
quote salesman birds what what he was
just like you know select one of the
jobs we offered he's gonna fill out the
census so you can't put a handle or
slash pigeons yeah
pitching guy dr. slash beater well he
had opened a new pet store on Broome
Street though in reality he refused to
sell any of the animals and he had 500
animals and birds in the shop not a lot
of pet store owners recognized the
cruelty of the business enough to be
like they're never leaving
that's a great adding as many as
possible I mean like that's like why I
can't like if I go to like a shelter or
I don't go to a pet store but what I
used to like I would you know you're
just like I want to take everything with
me yeah this is if I were to own a pet
shop that's right like they can't leave
they're my friends and by the way I
don't have a home anymore I live in my
pet store this is fun so but the pet
store is a front that's why he's not
selling anything because it's just a way
to you know bring money through okay
um the pet shop was kind of his
headquarters he hung out there hey this
snake is full of money hell is this hey
these guinea pigs are just full of
heroin they'd have a real oh boy across
the street was a public school one day
monk decided to start shooting out the
windows of the school sorry so I'm gonna
need a little more context of pasa just
because his move is dramatic okay well
he was just bored he's bored in his pet
store yeah and so he just decides he'll
start shooting across the street at the
windows of the school I bet you 20 years
ago that sounded a lot crazier it still
sounds crazy yeah but now it's like oh
yeah oh yeah so what they're yeah
the headmistress reported quote bullets
rained through the school rooms and the
children were in a panic
well I'm what god I don't know okay so
the headmistress runs out and starts
yelling at monk and I'm impressed yeah
he responds quote you're alright you're
a good spot for not calling the cops and
he did as I asked him so he she yelled
at him and he was like yeah you're all
good all right look at you with your
yelling gang up shooting sorry
yeah you're right so he's a nice guy
yeah a super nice guy yeah for sure that
what I would say he is sure the
Eastman's kept expanding causing more
and more friction with other gangs on
their borders monk was also a very good
diplomat and built alliances with rivals
and as he expanded he delegated crimes
to his lieutenants though he still liked
to quote beat up a guy once in a while I
keeps my hand in ya know for sure
you want to get bored well it's tough I
mean it's all paperwork at that look
like are you
not a little you know what he's supposed
to do just like sit around and delegate
and do page hear the stories about these
guys flogging strangers could you
imagine not being a guy oh don't even
yeah you might also been sitting at like
99 - so he was like I gotta get I gotta
go some of the names of the smaller gang
here we go
now the one part under the Eastman's
were the McCarthy's the Batavia Street
gang the lolly Meyers there we got the
red onions here we go and the squab
wheelman what happened but it did did
the names even make sense in that era to
people or were people like what the
hell's a squab what is it
squab wheelman what the hell's a squab
we all hey so the squab wheelman were
run by crazy butch what is happening
[Music]
monk had now ventured into another
business bike rentals interesting but he
wouldn't part with any of the bikes no
he did these to stay in the good graces
of monk the smaller gang members had to
rent at least one bike a week sure
whether they could ride it or not right
so that's in other words what we would
call a bribe Yeah right
the squab wheelman were actually named
in homage to monk squabs were pigeons
and whalemen her bikes okay so they
formed a gang named for hims quite an
homage that's pretty [ __ ] so that's
cool yeah
crazy Butch show why'd he was nicknamed
crazy one night when he attacked these
squab whaleman's own pool room sure so
he's he's the head of the Squa wheelman
crazy butch yes and he goes to the squab
wheelman and he had told all the squab
Willman and he and he attacks them quote
by way of testing their valour and
settling definitively in event of
trouble who would stick and who would
duck sure so he is crazy yeah yeah
okay butch in over six others burst into
the pool room shooting there were 60
wheelman in
side almost all fled one guy jumped out
a window and broke his neck that guy
yeah
that's embarrassing it was a test you
know I was kidding and playing along
can't move anything oh no my extremities
but not you I'm fine I stayed in I know
but I also pranked you guys yeah that's
not a prank that window was not real
glass and the ground is oh my gosh yeah
I I needed an ambulance
yeah we're not getting you April Fool by
the way you're not the gang anymore uh
okay
ha ha ha ha have you heard of the squab
Flatman yeah all right I'm gonna head to
this light how in my mind's eye but
butch zoom was sent away for burglary he
got a 4-year sentence so that he's in
trouble for yeah okay
monk always kept his true identity
hidden any constantly moves he was never
really telling him and everyone thought
it was a bunch of different names right
he started switching headquarters around
from saloons and pool rooms and even
wants to a graveyard he's trying to keep
the cops from knowing he's like Saddam
Hussein yes in caves and right eating
Doritos in a hole
what uh-huh how do you eat a wet burrito
that's what I was saying he's the - yeah
that's the craziest thing I ever serious
yeah as one of the really like dip him
in water no he would like take he would
have a bag of Doritos that he would pour
some water in the back what didn't the
[ __ ] does that even mean look wait I
mean I understand or a criminal you know
say what you will to me that's where I
go this man is not of this world okay
have you ever tried it just because you
know because if you do if you did would
you be like you become a dictator you're
like I'm better than all the others yes
they're just eating plain Doritos
they're not putting water in their bags
Yeah right
they would just get soggy and you
couldn't pick them out hey dude I'm not
the guy who's saying this is like I mean
did he shake it up and then drink it
like a no cheek no that's also it what
that helps you get there
no this you both are crazy
what I have read is that he would just
hit a pack you know it's like this is
one the US had captured him oh yeah this
is after yeah it wasn't like he was just
in the palace like they didn't catch him
they kill him
we killed him yes but there was they had
him on they put him over the head so
this is when he is this is during his
trial when he's like jailed no he was
bin Laden was never jailed
no no no said I'm just saying oh so I'm
saying yeah yeah Jesus Christ yeah
wait how long was he in prison for so
who's I mean you know not too long and
they were giving him Doritos hey yeah
they were like bribing him with Doritos
or something you know they're like
Saddam look play ball baby yeah hey will
you want another bag of Doritos water
cereal here you go baby
yeah what [ __ ] world is this it's it
was a different time I mean this is the
world you're describing is worse than
the world the world of the story and the
world we live in now is worse than both
okay okay so this case switching
locations he's sleeping in graveyards
the gang started working for Tammany
Hall stealing ballot boxes voting over
and over and working as quote sluggers
sure meaning people who just beat people
who didn't do what they wanted guys who
would come to vote and they're gonna
vote for the wrong guy they would
problem slug that guy right so tell that
guys brain got in the position it was
supposed to that's right and he saw the
light and voted for it at home right way
for a bag of wet Doritos and now doing
all this just game that gave the game
more immunity from the law the five
pointers are doing the exact same thing
okay mugs greatest enemy was the five
point leader Paul Kelly Paul was Italian
but took the name Paul Kelly for the
same reason monk took delay that's his
counterpart his real name was Apollo and
Tony knee of viscerally that's Italian
no that's Swedish okay Kelly went from
being a professional boxer to a gangster
and soon ran the five points gang
Paul was good-looking with great hair
and dressed impeccably he spoke four
languages total opposite of monk okay oh
we get a look at this guy yeah
I mean I guess that's oh yeah you like
that [ __ ] oh yeah that's it that's now
that's that's a nice-looking man yeah
the two actually liked each other
personally Paul said of Monk quote he's
a soft easygoing fella but has a gang of
cowards behind him second-story men flat
robbers and a mall buzzers yeah Jamal
buzzed right no mall buzzer yeah I
couldn't look that up I guess
well I'm sure it has well you know what
I'm you know I'm Mahler's mo ll mom oh
ma and what is that some hmm huh
what hmm feels like sure smaller mom an
mo ll mo mo mo buzzers are different
more sure more Oh buzzer I'm gonna get
out of here I'm gonna go at midnight on
April 13th 1901 to five point gang
members Peggy and James Donovan Peggy's
a guy sure the brothers obviously sure
they came into the Silver Dollar saloon
where a monk was drinking
Peggy shot it monk he missed hitting
18-year old Sam Samuel Franklin but he
hit him in his pocket watch that really
happens yeah you know there's back story
in that in that fat fat guys movie my
grandpa gave me this he said keep it I
didn't want to but two weeks ago I just
said it was gonna start keeping it and
now it's saved my life uh he goes
slightly wounded but not totally well
you had no idea what [ __ ] time it was
from then on nobody knows what time it
is
no it's saying four prostitute Oh
interesting
so miles a sex worker mall buzzer buzzer
so then what the hell's a buzzer maybe
it's they have sex with them or maybe
they're just maybe that maybe it's like
a pimp he's talking yeah that's kind of
what I was thinking yeah
okay there's the five points guys did
they have hats oh yeah that guy does not
there's one guy he [ __ ] showed up for
the pitch
and a hat day at his taies all short
[ __ ] - every day was hat day that's
true
so monk after the shooting happens monk
runs out into the street and the
donivans chase him and they catch him
and then Peggy pressed his gun against
monk's stomach and shot twice Jesus monk
then collapsed on the sidewalk and James
shot him behind the ear
holy [ __ ] police arrived James shot
twice at one of the cops before other
cops tackled him and Peggy got away
monk somehow still alive dazed and very
wounded started to walk it's not a good
time to walk no he's going for a little
walk I gotta go
stroll I'm gonna go buy a couple of I
gotta go get vegetables for a soup I'm
making I wish there were those lip
screws I don't know if he's really
walking either he's like you know he's
walking like he's in the throat yeah
it's a stagger so sure yeah I gotta go
he heads to the governor governor
hospital about a mile away okay so you
see marks a mile to the hospital yeah he
plugs the holes with his finger what he
sticks a minger yeah he's damning belly
fingering the girl the boy who put the
finger in the dike yeah doing that but
with his tummy
ah there's holes there now that
shouldn't be there he's giving himself a
Jack Horner belly that's right he's
bowling ball yeah he is absolutely
balling balling itself they perform
surgery on him and remove the bullets he
was not what about the fingers the
fingers they could not get out okay
he's not expected to survive so he gave
a statement and named his attackers okay
two days later the New York Times
reported that Edward Eastman who lived
at one along first Street had died okay
it's a good address yeah sure
but he wasn't actually dead no he was in
critical condition where he was for
weeks and he survived when he realized
he was actually gonna live he recanted
his deathbed statement and said he would
not
testify against whoever shot him hmm
street code yeah that's not a Squealer
sure in life yeah
and death you squeal and death he
squeezed everyone else did it that's
right hey you hurt me so weak after you
got out of the hospital a woman lured a
five pointer out of a bar where he was
shot and killed
police said monk had gotten his man okay
the five pointers and the Eastman's
battled for territory they had street
fights it was described as they quote
vicious fight for supremacy the greatest
and most bloody of a generation and the
three lowest Ward's of the city several
gang members were killed the disputed
territory between the Bowery was between
the Bowery and a dive bar on Pell Street
mostly full of Chinese immigrants and
opium dens that's the area they're
fighting for yeah okay so Kelly monk
would send patrols into the territory
with the instructions to beat up or
shoot anyone from the other gang okay so
there were a lot of small battles which
turned into one huge one in September
nineteen Oh two so a 5.0 was robbed and
beaten one night and then the next night
an Eastman gang member was beaten so bad
that he died and that's called murdered
I'm from what I've read are you doing
the Lion King in true
yeah okay so I'm gonna see if we have
any other no and this is all in
territory you said that's predominantly
like the Chinese section yeah so they're
happy about this influx - they're like
oh that's cool yeah and they're
immigrants there's no really Chinese
gangs yet and it's just like it mostly
opium dens for the the white guys hang
on okay that's what they're man I would
be so into the opium - I know good lord
yeah you'd have to peel me off of those
chips right so sixty Eastman's the next
night going to Chinatown splendas two
groups looking for five pointers they
had pistols knives and slung shots slung
shot I think it's like a really big
slingshot I thinking like if I can throw
bricks with it she could just fire
another guy at him put me in the
slingshot let's go boys one group met a
group of five pointers at white and
Walker streets and they shot and threw
bricks at each other okay they kept
fighting and writing all the way up to
Broadway there they were met by the
police who started fighting both gangs
and they stopped the ride but the
fighting started again at white and
center streets the cops rushed down and
put it into it they confiscated 13 guns
six knives and three black jacks
so please started patrolling the area in
groups of five quote pouncing on the
knots of fighters at every opportunity
and sending them to prisons in groups
and that finally stopped okay briefly
five days later okay the fighting flared
up again in 35 five pointers attacked a
pool room that was an Eastman hangout
monk was there okay
the fighting went on for ten minutes
three gang members were pushed out of
the second-floor windows one was an
Eastman gang member who died from a
fractured skull that will kill you that
ya hit against going dragging you know
by the way ten minutes and fighting
that's [ __ ] crazy for hours yeah it's
real life
exhausting yeah you've seen Roadhouse
the movie Rhoda I've lived Roadhouse
yeah Jack so it's like that yeah
the cops arrived and arrested 29 people
they found dozens of gun so once the
cops remote would run in every would
just throw that gun on the ground hey
look we found another one hey there's a
gun you know how some places have
sawdust on the faces in a pool cue
officer peanut shells well the the the
dead rabbits used to play pool with guns
to intimidate people well that's a game
where you really have to be aware of
where the guys shooting the ball behind
you
monk and the others were arraigned the
next day the prosecutor described them
as quote a disgrace to the city was he
no but marks attorney was an ex
Assemblyman who said they were all just
quote innocent boys arrested without
cause
gentlemen just a bunch of young
misguided look at monks moist mashed
potato head monkey over here hey I'm
sorry now during this time the Eastman's
were also fighting with the yaki yikes
sure I was gonna ask where the yaki eggs
were at although they were gang who
fought on independent gang fighting
under their five points okay
they were also much smaller gang they
were led by Big Dave Bernstein sure
they fought nightly battles one night
Big Dave was shot a few minutes after he
had gone to talk to monk at the hospital
he wouldn't name anyone quote anyway
I'll settle my own scores the doctors
there were like good okay yeah just
leave we'll see you in a week yes can
you also take your fingers out of your
heart I cannot get him out that's how we
do it in the city
they have songs of course the Eastman's
then shot into big Dave's saloon from
the outside to Yankee aches were
seriously wounded 19 year old kid twist
on East Way I love his first as solo
stuff is great kid twist was a little
kid twist was a lieutenant in Eastman's
gang okay he was arrested and he said he
acted in self-defense sure and no
witnesses would come forward to counter
his story so he was released she
that's a great yeah I mean that is a
good code if you are these guys yeah no
it is all is fine then an Eastman named
patty the snake was beaten by a group
led by Bill argument McCann tynin you
just knew you're sitting on gold he did
it yeah yeah wait
patty snake patty this is a fun game to
play on the school I love it patty snake
patty snake patty the snake was beaten
by a group led by Bill argument McMahon
hey how'd you get that name how'd you
get that day all right bill settle down
you should watch can you a question you
asked me if I'm settling down I'm not
settling here bill I didn't ask for a
[ __ ] beer who told you I want a
[ __ ] beer you did two minutes ago you
ordered it oh you ready two minutes ago
or at the bar it's a problem what were
you saying I have a problem I have a
problem
hey Bill I don't know why you're angry
at this guy he just brought you a beer
my anybody right now I'm not angry at
anybody you're pushing back on
everything you're pushing you're pushing
you are you're pushing period hey boys
country hi Bill we still on for tonight
yeah interesting twist didn't think
you'd go there okay so at the hospital
patty the snake told the cops quote I
ain't no Squealer I will attend to the
matter myself you know who would always
tattle was Petey the Squealer Peter this
gorilla know everything you want to know
that was a winner from here the names
this is the contact information well you
fellas want to hear oh boy I'll sing -
the days over fellas I think we gotta
get rid of Beatty the Squealer hey
what's the problem [ __ ] right here guys
there's no problem nothin first of all
your name is really bad yeah but I only
got it on account of the way I act
you're a Squealer well yeah but you're
the one who stabbed that guy two weeks
ago okay that's a good example of what
you shouldn't be doing in the gang oh
okay now that I know I'll be better what
are you doing Oh what do you whispering
nothing
I just was nothing let's have a meeting
who wants popcorn it just was invented I
may be huh okay see you guys later
wait you're not going anywhere yeah all
right
there's a good meet no huh huh hey
everybody write down your contact
information
hey Jimmy the stabber you want to take
care of this he had no promos yeah yeah
you did it you did and I need this bad
stamp made
so when paddy got a hospital two days
later he he went to wait at Bill the
arguments place sure and when bill
argument shut up paddy quit pressed a
revolver to the base of his skull and
blew off the top of his head Jesus
Christ who's arguing now nobody
yeah bills done argument please started
now making raids to stop the Yankee
yikes and the Eastman's from fighting
now some of the pool rooms were set up
like labyrinths so when cops broke
through the armored doors of one they
found themselves in a room with three
doors they were welcome police officers
it's time to choose so they broke
through the first door and they found
themselves in a room with three doors
man well money only was tripping out
here a little bit did we take mushrooms
hey we did take mushrooms okay but we'll
be fine
some tells me if we just take another
tool we'll be okay
they backed up and tried the second door
and found a room with three doors it's
now hey Billy I'm going crazy what is
going on what the [ __ ] is this okay they
went back and tried the third door and
found a room with three doors finally a
cop realized they were over the pool
room and he smashed with an axe through
the floor and they jumped down okay
make your own door so you go door you
got to improvise so eventually the
fighting led the Tammany politicians to
crack down they were worried that an
all-out war would break
and an upset to voters who were pretty
indifferent to gangsters killing each
other at this point
cool so they're like oh it's gangsters
killing gangsters but then if it's all
at war than other people start getting
hurt okay so politician Tom Foley had to
sit down with the gangs now Tom Foley
you gotta be a little nervous for that
intervention he's the guy over on the
right the guy who looks like he's
wearing a weird bird hat yeah okay so
boy those are that you that's a real
that that picture is those are already
Hall guys look at them yeah
bunch of pricks yeah so I sit down he
said while he understood there would be
beatings and murders every now and then
as part of business hey you make an
omelet sometimes you gonna kill a guy
right we understand gentlemen yes open
warfare would cause everyone trouble and
if the fighting didn't stop Tammany Hall
would stop protecting the gangs so monk
and Kelly agreed to end the war okay Tom
Foley then went out because the
reporters are waiting outside because
they know the meetings happened sure and
he goes out and he says quote the
representatives the of these rival
factions have been given their words
open start again the representative
these of these rival factions have given
their words that they will never more be
bad oh that's not what they said right
what an era where you are having a
politician come out to talk about how
the negotiations between gang factions
is gone and now with that I'll take your
questions
uh yeah what the [ __ ] is happening what
I don't know I said a thing okay
it sounded great when it came out of my
mouth sure yeah see Keys write down and
we'll be good that's not how this
operates it will be in the future okay
yeah
the representatives of these rival
factions haven't given their words that
they will Nevermore be bad thus ending
the necessity of calling out the police
deserves to quell riots and disperse
gangs with our pistols clubs and other
weapons after the deal was signed they
went to New Dorp Staten Island to seal
the deal with a chowder okay so just one
of those regular sort of culminating
chowder moments just boys and to make it
official let's all have big bowls of
chowder boys it's time for a bowl of
clams in liquid we are about to make it
official once we go to the clam signing
Kelly monk and a bunch of their
followers drank and ate and then headed
back on the ferry at midnight everyone
eat their oath chowder hey I got to
Manhattan they march through the streets
in South Ferry with a brass band fully
had paid for leading them sure then
hundreds of five pointers started
shooting their revolvers into the air
here we go so this is the day of the
announcement they shouldn't con them
drunk the day of the proclamation a
piece is the piece that this is
celebrating the piece announced after
the chowder summit they have walked this
night with a brass band hired by one of
the Tammany Hall cries and now shooting
into the sky shooting into the sky and
here we are again as they got to their
territory 15 cops tried to restore order
they were badly beaten by the mob this
is again the day yes yes at the end of
the day of the shirt so monk set up a
prototype the Mafia would use four
generations in New York protection
rackets he wasn't just a legit
businessman
it wasn't sorry it wasn't just legit
businessman and that he did the
protection with he forced thieves
brothel owners gambling house owners
gamblers all to pay up and the kind
Tammany Hall got a cut of everything so
this is the right the mob the mob model
being that you or the mob well as I like
to call it yeah that you are like hey
give us money and you get you won't get
hurt
yes live your life yeah right okay so
all right now the Tammany Hall guys are
happy they got money coming in these
guys will help him win votes by 1900
months gang had 1200 men in it that's a
that's a hefty number for a game
especially in this era 1200 they were
expensive clothes drank top-shelf booze
and had money to burn
monks gang united different types of
gangs to further their collective
interest other smaller gangs paid him
tribute and could be called upon for
battle he had his lieutenants write up
reports of the crimes they'd carried out
okay he's considered the first gangster
to take advantage of labor disputes he
took money to stop union organizers and
beat up two leaders after he would often
take the money from both sides right
sometimes he would send a gang members
to literally work both sides of a strike
his gang members his he would have guys
cracking heads of Union guys and also
guys in the end fighting back right okay
what is that what's the upside he's
getting money okay both sides okay
gotcha right but aren't you like hey I
think we're getting screwed like once he
starts beating your side yeah it's not
great right okay so bad yeah I mean it's
a one-time payment mom yeah it's not
yeah not recurring that's right mom
could pay off the cops but one occasion
he did not and the cops raided his
headquarters they took out two wagon
loads of brass knuckles which is a is
that a metric weighing system
yeah wagon was a metric wing so sure
they took out wagon load sounds like a
gang member by the way oh well I'm sure
it was I'm wagon loads hey how are you
carry this I could but I don't my gear
to AG you loads of brass knuckles slung
shots
Blackjacks knives pistols and other
weapons so to wagon loads of weapons
sure as monks power grew he moved the
business his business out of lower
Eastside he started collecting debts
doing personal vendettas scaring off
businesses and silencing witnesses up
town so it's quite a portfolio yeah he's
killing it yeah it's versatile one of
his lieutenants prices a
/ on the cheek with a knife $1 to $10
hmm interesting
shot in the leg $1 to $25 interesting so
both could be purchased for $1
potentially yeah if it was the right
situation well shot in the arm 5 to 25
okay so now we're getting up throwing a
bomb 5 to 50 so still possible for $5 to
get someone to throw a bomb murder $10
to $100 so for double the bomb throwing
price you could potentially get a murder
out of his right so the reason the
prices are different is and if you're on
the lower east side you don't have a lot
of money but if you're on if you're
uptown you have the cash to pay it's
quite a sliding scale okay monkey had
the courts paid off one cop quote monk
Eastman was arrested 30 times but we
never got him dead to rights and had to
let him go animal love continued as he
grew more powerful powerful he collected
more pigeons and cats he now had 500
pigeons and a hundred cats so [ __ ] up
pet store if you think about it I mean
at this point I'm not a pet store
anymore there's a [ __ ] up pet store I
mean essentially his pet store has rival
gangs inside of it yeah it's a nightmare
it with the pigeons hey what a cat I
mean the cats are winning the pigeons
aren't doing [ __ ] yeah I guess it's it's
not great for the patients it's not
great for the pigeons but they have
numbers they do have numbers but they
have flight okay I agree my money's on
the cats yeah now as much as they're a
better truce with the five points they
were still fights happening here and
there most between individual gang
members but on September 15th 1903
fighting flared up a big time between
the two gangs 40 Eastman's started a
fight with eight men in a bar then they
headed for the Bowery and started more
fights some 5 pointers decided to raid
an Eastman hangout the hangout was a
quote 50-foot crevice between two rows
of tenements it's a great spot to hang
out it's a great name for a joint - a
crevice another crevice tonight I
thought we were calling it the ditch
well it's really more of a crevice hey
you guys I found a
a spot for a hangout it's a big ditch
hey guys we going to the gourd so so
this is their hangout both sides pulled
out guns and started shooting each other
the five pointer was killed
more and more gang members joined the
shootout the police arrived and both
sides shot at them the street lights
were shot out so the cops couldn't see
by midnight over a hundred gang members
were shooting at each other
Jesus so at this point is fully like um
hey me guys not the player remember this
summit chowder guys chowder all right
listen I understand what's happening we
need to get more chowder down there
right now guys we we didn't over chowder
and we ate it out of bread balls coming
that's a deal the Gophers came shot
eight times the Gophers came from Hell's
Kitchen sure and started shooting at
both gangs interesting one of the
Gophers would later say quote a lot of
the guys was popping at each other so
why shouldn't we do a little popping
ourselves hey it's pretty much the
Gopher mentality if you think about it
it's Kurt just like well it's there why
not [ __ ] it up
finally the police were able to gather a
large enough group to head in and as
they did gang members threw bricks at
them from rooftops the battle then moved
and raged along two miles of streets Wow
the path of destruction and number of
casualties was huge but by that so that
people just getting shot left and right
right and not gang members right people
and they descend then finally they just
disappeared into the night and went
their own ways okay
the dead and wounded were laying in the
streets in some cases for hours a five
pointer died at the hospital from quote
a gunshot wound and strangulation
interesting well you gotta hedge your
bets cover your bases right but I'm
dying from a gunshot from this two
wounded gang members were locked up a
monk was one of them under the name Joe
Morris hey I'm Joey Morris they said he
was he was just a passerby I just
I just I was singing a gun that I found
I picked it up well I could tell you
I've sure been hit in the face a lot but
uh I set him slide view Wow like he's
got a face like a frying pan it's real
flat yeah it's not great the police
would not could not find one witness so
two miles of shooting if you'll be
getting shot yeah but and no one is good
but if you've watched two miles of yeah
just a war yeah and you're like no I'm
good
nah I'm good I feel like me talking
about it results in more street murder
so I'm good
and then the Tammany Hall lawyers came
to help everyone was let go but the
battle was so crazy even Tammany Hall
had to deal with it they threatened to
take away both gangs protection
protection once again Tommy a monk had a
face-to-face meeting peace was declared
again what kind of a soup do we want to
dot the t's with after Tom Foley
organized a ball and their monk and
Kelly shook hands in the middle of the
dance floor Wow
very high school rom-coms right right
okay
but the police commissioner was finished
he met with the city inspector an
assistant DA to see what they could do
and they started making raids he charged
six corrupt cops with neglect of duty
interesting that's how you know someone
serious yeah the night after the battle
the five corners were holding a
fundraiser for the wounded gangsters
bills the gang is holding a fundraiser
yeah isn't your ability to raise funds
pretty much just to go rob well maybe
the community should give back for all
the help they receive fair point they
wore black badges with silver printed
letters that said quote we mourn our
loss interesting it's nice
cops came to the fundraiser and started
beating heads the inspector jumped on a
table and yelled quote the Paul Kelly
Association is dead from now on the Paul
Keller okay right
after the raid the inspector told the
press quote I think we have succeeded in
putting the Paul Kelly Association out
of business yeah that's right yeah
exactly we want to do is Neville
Chamberlain the moment that's right
right as soon as you feel like it's over
mission accomplished done done done put
up the banner the next day Paul Kelly
held a funeral for one of the Dead five
pointers and 2005 pointers marched to
Brooklyn Wow obviously he wasn't at a
business the cops hit the Eastman's next
they staked out there hanging out the
cops wore disguises so they wouldn't be
recognized in their uniforms ready hats
scarves oh they had scarves and slouch
hats I don't know and just as trolley
conductors motormen butchers printers
and street cleaners some more fake
mustaches and fake beards jeez wow that
era I mean the fake beard in this era
must be a nightmare it probably was just
like a horse tail like how are you I'm
growing it out yes I always forgot about
the old mustache before I have a sip of
this ale then they charged in and
started beating the Eastman and made
arrests anonymous cop told a reporter
the gangs were quote going to get a dose
of their own medicine they are going to
be beaten within an inch of their lives
by the police whenever the slightest
excuse is offered sorry and you're the
good guy I'm the cop right okay just
bottoms sure cool Congrats yes but all
the gang members were released by the
courts because the courts are all bought
off right things start to calm down a
bit because an election was coming and
Tammany Hall needed calm though Kelly
and an Eastman lieutenant challenged
each other to a boxing match in the
cellar below a bar I like this yeah
Kelly was outweighed by 80 pounds okay
and he beat the living [ __ ] out of the
guy okay now this was incredibly
offensive and upsetting to the Eastman's
and they now wanted revenge there was a
fair fight he is still mad that I got
beaten up right after the election was
over the fighting started again an
Eastman was beaten had his nose broken
and and an ear bit off
look Jesus got take a near man you got
to do everything you can you got to get
in there you got a fight you got a stab
like if I lose an ear in a fight that's
what I'm retiring from fighting there's
the cops look at them monk told Kelly to
exact retribution on his own man or he
would okay Tammany Hall held peace talks
again this time they agreed to settle
their differences in the ring okay
Paul Kelly and monk Eastman would have a
bare-knuckle fight the winner would get
the disputed territory holy [ __ ]
we what come on is real Palestine they
held the fight one night in the Bronx
everyone took the train up and walked
two miles to the site the ref was from a
rival gang who had no affiliation with
either gang I love it it's like yes
while he is a gang member he doesn't
care for either one of our gangs that's
right he's no choice I'm from the sad
rabbits okay yeah he could call it buddy
it's okay when you're out there take a
couple pigeon and a cat you know give me
a couple fair call Oh can't just kill
pigeon all right so you got a fat cat
that's awesome okay it says you gotta
say she had animal feline it's awesome
so you know remember make his count a
little bit shorter than mine okay hey
buddy it's okay it's okay
yeah it's all right but my god this is a
dog I'm talking to you monk uh was
stockier and five inches taller than
Paul Kelly
so Paul Kelly was four foot to the Paul
Kelly was started out as a boxer before
he turned into a gangster so okay both
guys had a corner man sure a cup man I
cut mantacorn him each round went on
until one fighter was knocked down okay
and the corner man had a minute to wake
up his guy or the fight was over okay
minutes a minute so CTE prominent yeah
both monk and Kelly went down multiple
times but were able to keep fighting the
fight went on for close to two hours
holy [ __ ] yeah it's not great it's
really bad this is a bad thing
Wow yeah they finally both collapse from
exhaustion but kept trying to hit each
other from the ground okay
so how does that work it's the bet I
don't care it's kind of sleep fight mmm
mmm a kind of thing right and then lay
yeah they were pulled apart and the
fight was declared a draw so does that
mean right so it means that nobody wins
in the DA and the disputed territory
still up for grabs
okay sad you some some said it was fixed
but they had a sad rabbit well they also
punch each other for two hours so I'm
not sure that's true
On February second 1904 monk and a buddy
Chris Wallace saw shit-faced guy come
out of Jack's all-night restaurant he's
standing on the street and the guy takes
out his money and starts counting it
well so this man is asking to be rung
and yelling robbed me so much money
Monken wallace saw two guys standing
nearby about to rob him so they stepped
in and robbed him first which is the
nice thing to do yeah step in and you
commit the crime that's where the bad
guys do yeah home town yeah examine
bandage so they take the guy's money but
the other two guys weren't robbers
turned out they were Pinkertons probably
who had been hired to keep an eye on the
drunk guy who was a rich kid what a
weird situation that is - yeah
so the Pinkertons just started shooting
and okay mr. Pinkerton right mug and
Wallace pulled out their guns and shot
back no one's hitting each other because
they're Monken Wallace Yeah right
they ran and shot as they went as the
Pinkertons chased it shot back but the
only damage that occurred from the
shootout was when monk ran out of
bullets and threw his gun at a Pinkerton
and it smashed through the window of a
store and onto a teacup set oh no my tea
now that my mother was nothing Lesure
upset oh yeah well oh well you could do
it you won but a sec reduce Marshall
good cheesehead you've crossed a line
sir
a cop happened to be there and he hit
monk on the head and knocked him out
okay
monk woke up in jail and as usual he
didn't give a [ __ ] he figured he'd be
out soon right
the problem though was the Pinkertons
they would not take money to change
their story and they wouldn't be
intimidated that's a problem yeah so all
of a sudden he had a high bail slapped
on him that no one could pay monk was
charged with attempted murder first
degree and assault and then he got hit
with another charge of trying to kill a
guy two weeks earlier and also he ruined
it Catherine found another fella and a
teacup is water with what was full
sources shy of a full set now hmm
governor nope monk was found guilty of
assault in the first degree he got 10
years in sing-sing Wow when he heard the
sentence he was most concerned about his
pigeons I like I can't I can't not love
this man
he asked the court to allow him to
remain in the tombs until he could find
someone to take care it was 500 Birds
and the judge was like alright this is a
better time I don't care what anyone
says as he was being taken to prison
a crowd of 5,000 gathered to say goodbye
kid twist tried to run the Eastman's
while monk was in prison but he was shot
dead on May 14th by Louie the lump lets
Louie the LOB right there jeez okay who
was a five pointer they fought over a
woman Paul Kelly was never able to take
advantage of monk being gone okay which
you would think he would then you know
completely take over right there were
two attempts on Kelly's life in 1905
once he was stabbed in the back and
another time he was shot three times
even though he was wounded he was seen
quote running down the Bowery hatless in
the direction
of the Occidental hotel what does he's
what's his plan what's wrong with that
man he does not a hat Yeah right that's
what everyone's talking about is he's
bleeding he's been shot three times the
good Lord he doesn't ever had well
hopefully someone shoots him oh good
someone has probably hat related Kelly's
influence became less and less police
came under more pressure to crack down
on the gangs the five point of hype
owners headquarters was shut down the
gang they went into decline they moved
from Five Points to Midtown Kelly went
even further uptown 116th Street and
started working as a labor organizer
mm-hmm he became vice president of the
Longshoremen's Association and changed
his name back to Palo Vasarely sure he
kept one foot an organized crime in one
in labor okay what's nice time option
not very rare right right is these are
the guys who started it needs two guys
monk got out in June 1909 there was no
one waiting for him when he came out of
prison it was just a farmer there who
offered him work all right no boy I
think you could replace my tractor hey
you like pigs yeah you got a job is
there anyone else here it's just it's
just me so when I went in I was so
popular it just seems like one bed
what's the deal you act pigs I've
answered that question one bed from here
for the pigs all of us did you did
people think I was gonna get later no
one here but me
your friend Pigman your name again is
Pigman hmm your eyes are open so that is
um particularly troubling are you
sleeping or you want a job oh my god
you're the pig aren't you oh they told
me about guys like you inside you need a
job don't you
look dude I'm not pig banging you okay
I'm not playing slam Pig I've heard
about this game
all right fine come on get in the truck
you could sit up front with Big Daddy so
he took the job he reported to a parole
office job yeah he walks outside head
and there's a shut up he walked outside
and there's a [ __ ] farmer waiting for
him he the first thing he says is do you
want to come work for me just simpler
time that's just too simple also isn't
it good that ex-cons can get jobs I just
look I think he needed zip recruiter he
didn't just a quick an option some
options but he's on parole and he needs
to have a job and a report really Pro
officers who Dave if a dude is just yeah
it's got a pig mask on yeah he's part of
anonymous okay all right so he thinks he
meets a guy the first guy he meets he's
like yeah yeah you're fine and it's up
he has to he has to see his parole
officer up state so it's all it works so
yeah no there's not any problem with
this in September he went to a hospital
for quote some internal trouble which is
causing me agony monk did yeah okay when
his clothes were off the doctor asked
him if he had been in a war because of
all the scars sure monk said yes a half
dozen Wars on the Lower East Side
hey I got still got the funnies after
his prose up he headed to New York his
pigeons are gone sure his cats are gone
no one wanted to have much to do with
him the old gangsters knew he was he
knew were gone or in jail or dead
okay Tammany Hall didn't give a [ __ ] he
had no power monk started selling opium
and then doing opium cops settled old
scores by beating him up all the time
people constantly were informing on him
just because people who hate him from
back in the day I'll just lie and say
[ __ ] still he got married again okay she
was just 20 he's like 40 okay the cops
cracked down on gangs again because
there was another flair for fighting and
monk was a big name for the press so
they arrested him over opium charges and
got eight months when he was released
the cops said if he came near New York
they would beat him daily and who was
awaiting outside of the prison when he
came it was another Pigman or was it
another was it some guy who's just like
I live up in the mountains and I need a
guy to help me count rocks well all
right you got a guy waiting is that a
job yeah it's shorter how does that pay
it pays it rocks you get to keep all the
weird shaped ones and the ones that are
sphere shaped will they go in the rock
bank how do you make how do you believe
how do you make money
we live on ROC currency up here in the
mountains you're gonna love it
I've seen your resume I know you as a
pig boy you're gonna make a great fit
for the Rock Bank come on up to the
hills in the mountains live with rocks
and me it'll just be me you and a bunch
of shale okay yeah and by the way we got
to hold hands that's part of your job
now true I used to run a gang like
wheezed where I used to paint
we all got Eustace now come on over here
hold my hand we got some pebbles to
count and then we're gonna put them in
the rock vault though you're my best
friend
bet you wish someone else was waiting
out here with maybe another option of
died at that time well the time I put my
fingers in my tummy a Shinto figured
yourself damn much silly not now you
live in a rock side with me yeah I think
he made some mistakes in my life well I
did too look where I am you think that
I'm happy with our ally ended up I used
to be a painter I used to paint
beautiful beautiful landscapes but then
I broke my hand one day in a bar fight
and I couldn't paint no more so then I
went up to the hills and I invented a
rock Bank so now it's you me and we just
work at the bank of rock come on this
hand ain't gonna hold itself soon okay
until you make sense that man definitely
has a beard by the way
so he went upstate he was arrested in
Buffalo in 1914 he fled to New York on
another charge in 1915 so you know he
goes back to New York to get out of she
was he gets arrested a crowd of a
thousand people came to the train
station to see monkeys Minh shipped off
upstate he got two years in eleven
months when he got out he returned to
the Lower East Side where he was
relentlessly harassed by police World
War one was in full swing and at 43 monk
Eastman volunteered to fight whoa this
is by the way a guy here like yes for
sure
this is a twist yeah he served in France
with Orion's Roughnecks
and in one battle he was wounded and
gassed but refused treatment and crawled
under enemy fire to carry his wounded
sergeant to safety the sergeant said a
monk saved his life other actions that
he did were also considered heroic and
he was discharged honorably in 1919 when
he was asked what he thought of the war
he said quote fought the Battle of New
York there were lots of dance halls in
the Bowery tougher than that so-called
great war of theirs
Jesus yeah okay because there's tons of
mustard gassing in the Bowery is that
true no okay for his crimes at some
point he had lost his citizenship at
some point at some point he was just
like criminals yeah they took away his
internship when people learned a
petition to restore it was started and
signed by all his officers and almost
every man in his regiment and Governor
Al Smith then restored his rights and
monk went back to a life of petty crime
interesting twist a man it really felt
like we were just hearing about like the
comeback story and then the second that
he's kind of back well I'm like equal
and he's like yeah you know what I
should pay I'm gonna kill a guy
the day after Christmas 1920 he was
meeting with other men at the Bluebird
Cafe in lower Manhattan around 4:00 a.m.
the men got into an argument over money
and I know at any meeting that is
happening at 4:00 a.m. it's not great
not great it's drinking yeah
monk and a guy named Gerry Bohan really
got into it they were partners Bohan was
a corrupt prohibition agent and Bohan
left and monk followed him out into the
street and accused him of being a thief
Bohan then shot a monk several times
with a pistol and monk Eastman was dead
they had a funeral with full military
honors
they held a full military procession
through the streets of Brooklyn as a
crowd of 10,000 watched he was buried
with a full military honors at Cypress
Hills Cemetery his murderer served three
years in prison his murderer got three
years yeah
Paul Kelly died in 1919 who was just
sent to like sentencing back then was
just like you rolled like an eight sided
die yeah but a lot of countries think
rehabilitation is the way to go like
where our sentencing is really [ __ ]
crazy commit other countries yeah but
the sentence they saying murder should
be more than three years I am I guess
you could say that my point and if we
were to condense it would be yeah this
guy should have gotten more in three
years for murder but I bet they to an
account like well the two criminals blah
Madiba long right yeah but a war hero a
guy who has a procession going down
would that I mean he's a war hero
where's the petty criminal
where is he a criminal mastermind on an
all-new monk Paul Kelly had died in 1936
and natural causes he just stayed as a
crooked labor guy so the boys those are
the boys want to see his funeral
procession yeah I want to look at him
again too
so here they are carrying his casket to
the street oh boy yes he's got an
American flag on it you're given the guy
who killed him three years here that's
it look how many people there Wow
so you know military hero party boy I
mean it does look like a party boy can I
see that first shot you show me you have
the M
of him yes very first picture yeah oh
man you had some [ __ ] man yeah that that
face tells some stories that guy's been
in so many fights Jesus so I really this
is it is that let me ask you this is
that a more messed up time or is now a
Mormon that's that's what I'm I don't
know like so it's more messed up in this
sense that more people are dying from
yeah disease I mean are they though I
mean well but it's in general it sounds
like basically the the general street
violence was higher so you are we
probably have we talking about crime is
crime worse I'm talking about the system
I mean what's the difference between
Tammany Hall and what we have now
exactly like they're just letting people
die from opioids and the health care
system is killing people massively and
that's all straight-up corruption fossil
fuels are killing tons of people are
doing nothing about it and and the
argument would be that like in order to
get away from a system like the one the
time that monk lived and that's why we
have that's why we live in a
surveillance state yeah but really all
we've sacrificed in a surveillance state
is our privacy yeah for probably no real
benefit if you were to like put it all
on the scales Oma's ative none there's
no benefit they're not stopping any of
the shootings that are happening they're
not stopping any of the things that are
going on what this podcast needs to
become and I think this is heart rate
party-boy Park this is how we treat the
back nine a pig party boycott this is
what we do okay we could get a time
machine and we go to other times and
read them stories about now and watch
them be like wait what happens what do
you guys develop I mean look there was
there was I mean there's a whole section
there's a giant part it's Manhattan and
it's just like whatever goes you know
right and the gangs control everything
and
and but thinking you think about known
the cops are gangs and exactly like the
cops and Chicago tortured all these
people and I think the cops are killing
black people left and right yeah and
they and the way they have Punisher
tattoos and you know there's gangs like
I said there's Sheriff gangs here that
have tattoos that are [ __ ] gang
members a sheriff gang so [ __ ] I don't
know like it seems better but it's just
that I think that's really what it is
they've just made it seem better it
seems better but we're obviously on the
verge of something very catastrophic
happening and really some bad [ __ ] going
down so in a couple years we'll probably
be like the monk era made a lot right
when you could just a cop he'd be like
what's your name you'd be like I'm Scott
Weiland I would least don't double
pilots you could look at like it and say
oh Tammy I was fixing elections but all
of our elections are fixed there's
gerrymandering that I like by people
vote there's all this [ __ ] nonsense
going on the our president loses by
three million votes it's all [ __ ]
the whole system is [ __ ] garbage
right and then and then they're just all
paid off - if I can take money and tell
people to [ __ ] off and there's probably
some people who listen to this and
they're like they can't get political
about this episode no that's true I just
think that you know like at least ballot
stuffing right is it it's almost like
honest dishonesty it's it's you can see
it yeah you can catch someone doing it
yeah as opposed to electronic voting
without paper trails and gerrymandering
like you said and it's like those are I
mean in truth a guy noxious gases and
truth a guy like this now becomes a
governor or yeah or or a guy who [ __ ]
runs a bank like their social yeah right
they're sociopaths also they're [ __ ]
killing people like crazy and [ __ ]
people over left and right and they
don't give a [ __ ] like this guy based on
his smarts and what he did he would be a
leader of some sort and just find the
white-collar way to go to you know make
his empire and be his thing yeah well if
you kill someone as a white-collar
criminal you're fine you're fine you
literally didn't
thing in their opinion yeah how many
people went to jail after the last class
what is it
no bankers no what's the number it's a
zero that's an interesting number it
doesn't interesting numbers yeah well
look at times is it nope
Aaron how do you feel about America yeah
and here I was just thinking monk was a
Tony Shalhoub vehicle I know right
so mistake I would love to [ __ ] go
back in time meet guys like this oh man
I mean right yeah you just don't get to
meet people like that
no just honestly just to be a fly on the
wall for this air just to be like oh my
god that's him
yeah thank you sit there and listen to
him just watch him like plugging his
bullet holes be like dude you are and
you are believe me a machine and
literally all we'd have to do to get to
know him is wait outside the jail and
just like give a better page yeah oh my
god I'm offering a cotton some pigs I
got a rock Bank hi this is Dave I'm
Gareth we you're gonna talk into a thing
that looks like a Mike whatever it looks
like a stick with a foam on it and you
just talking about for like an hour tops
sometimes we go and of course that's one
that didn't record Katya oh my god [ __ ]
I didn't hit record went to 1901 didn't
record [ __ ] the guy seemed cool - he's
like we got it alright mmm
Godspeed everybody gobble gobble we love
you and we love each other that's the
main thing we don't fight never fought
we fought for each other what any times
do you say we've fun I'd say like three
or four times if you don't then yeah and
even then they're just like we're just
do against gosh yeah that is what's so
great about the internet and read it
people why do they reach oh yeah no no
yeah you just back that was like I'm
gonna bring all my childhood problems
into this podcast
mother and father despise each other I'm
in my room without supper again alright
so we got our we got our corporate
corporate hood stuff so we're moving
forward quickly with a change tan and
getting the website up yes and exciting
things coming on that end to come flee
okay alright thank you thanks everybody
Godspeed God love God God God blessings